at least another day another victory for
you but this one once again it wasn't
easy especially out of the opening it
felt like she was putting a lot of
pressure on you you weren't really
comfortable with the opening phase were
you yeah
um he played like this 94 movie which I
wasn't expecting and
um I actually like know this position
except with the bishop on a D3 not on E2
so here I was pretty annoyed because
usually you play like 92
um but yeah so I felt like in out of the
opening I was definitely a prepared I
was probably worse
um but I didn't see like that she had
like an immediate win with her attack
she was definitely I thought she was
still like better
um I I think you still had a slight Edge
out of the opening but at the same time
she was you know finding the right move
yeah
by the way you had you had an amazing
opportunity here did you uh even
consider this idea with Knight takes C4
oh no no I didn't
I'm going to C4 now
it's Rook F7 you take oh no I definitely
didn't see anything
I just played G3 pretty quickly yes and
then I mean here I was pretty happy with
the position I thought I'd like either
win or draw
um and the explained was this sequence
of trying to force her at least push her
to play this move G4 and solidify the
structure
um yeah so actually uh so G4 she I don't
think she really wants to take on F4
because uh I have work takes and then I
get like the file
um so after achieve four uh Queen to G5
uh I wasn't sure whether I was like
winning or not but here I thought like I
could uh play on The Queen side in the
ending uh well her play on the king side
wouldn't really be that as like drawn
and she did try something in the game
after we traded Queen with like H5 H4
but maybe H4 was a bit premature because
now I can take and the G4 Pawn is weak
very nice and it was at this moment when
you played the move H3 you kind of
coaxed her into maybe taking on H3 maybe
but even if she doesn't take it the
position is almost hopeless yeah she did
take and you finished with this
beautiful
um calculated shot very nice Alice right
now you're by yourself in the lead how
are you feeling about your chances how
feeling about your place so far uh I
think my place so far is definitely but
I'm really happy with this game because
I thought like out of the opening I
might be in some trouble especially
since she seemed so well prepared
um but overall I mean I guess like
there's still five more rounds to go
it's not even like half of their
tournament yet
um and I'll be playing Rochelle uh who I
think I mean when I checked you with
better I think no I think Rochelle is
not in a good position even though a lot
of things have happened okay maybe
Rochelle is actually doing quite well
right now yeah so she'll be only we have
a point behind me so it's important I
guess for me to try not to lose
tomorrow's round
um but yeah so far I'm happy with my
play and I hope that I'll be able to
keep it up congratulations uh Alice and
sorry for keeping you so long in the
studio but it was a fun game you were
watching I saw you you were like
approving of mishra's moves as well
nodding your head very nice
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
absolutely our congratulations as well
Alice and indeed